[موسيقى]
اليوم تودعنا العقارب وتقول لنا مع
السلامه
ولا رايح تزورنا الا بعد سنه تقريبا وغدا
الجمعه اول موسم الحميمين وهو اول مواسم
الربيع الحار وسمي بهذا نتيجه لحم وجه
السماء وحمو باطن الارض ونتيجه لهذا الحمو
تخرج الزواحف والهوامه السامه العقارب
والثعابين من مخابيئها ولهذا يسميه عرب
الباديه بالشام بسعد الخبايا وقالوا في
سعد الخبايا تطلع الحيايا الحميمه الاول
اخر موسم برد بياع الخبل عباته الحميمه
الثاني اول برد موسم العجوز وهو برد نادر
الحدوث ولا يحدث الا مره وحده كل 12 سنه
واذا حدث فهو مهلك وقالوا يا ربنا يا رحيم
اكفنا برد
الحميمين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ولفصل الربيع موسمين موسم العقارب هو موسم
الحميمين العقارب معتدله لا تخلو من هجمات
برد مباغته والحميمين ايضا معتدله لا تخلو
من عبور نسمات برد عابره ومطره منبت
للربيع الصيفي وغمامه ملطف للاجواء
ساصبروا حتى تتجلى كل غمه وتاتي بما تهواه
نفس المقادير واني لبئس العبد ان كنت ايسا
من الله ان دارت علي
الدوائر
[موسيقى]